[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le football brésilien c'est Pelé les
Français en savent quelque chose
s'appelait il ne fait qu'une bouchée du
Brésil oui mais voilà Pelé leur a coupé
les jambes avec son premier
et pourtant l'équipe de France était en
vert regardez cela il s'en va à cœur
joie les avants français
toutes ces combinaisons finissent par
être payant
voilà comment vesney ski est gagné
alors Monsieur Pelé reprend le Bricoman
de son équipe il donne des frissons aux
défenseurs français Bonnel perd la tête
il faut que j'adversaire
penalty pelait se paie un second but et
puis il rentre à nouveau dans sa
coquille
les avant français ressortent le grand
jeu de 800 tête lui c'est le pellet de
l'équipe française il va le montrer dans
un instant voilà comment on donne la BU
à ses partenaires
m’épeler lui il préfère marquer tout
seul ces bus et ce qu'il fait et on peut
dire que c'est lui qui a battu l'équipe
de France qui d'ailleurs ne méritait pas
de perdre
[Applaudissements]
il est long le chemin qui mène à la
gloire et c'est sans doute pour cela que
les bébés matters espagnols prennent les
devants
on fait timidement connaissance avec le
fauve lui aussi un bébé un bébé taureau
guerre plus rassuré il est vrai
courageux mais pas téméraire
enfin c'est le grand moment le matador
affronte le monstre
ce n'est plus un faux c'est un lapin ce
roller
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le style de la nouvelle vague avec le
taureau ce serait sans doute une autre
histoire
[Musique]
mais tout de même maman est fière de son
petit prodige
[Musique]
un petit prodige qui attendra de ne plus
pleurer pour être un homme et qui aura
encore l'occasion d'apprendre qu'il est
vraiment très long et douloureux le
chemin qui mène à la gloire
[Musique]
au cours du 18e voyage du général de
Gaulle Saint-Dizier aura été une étape
importante le chef de l'État y a
rencontré le maire de Berlin Ouest
monsieur Willy Brand et a évoqué avec
lui le problème de Berlin et l'avenir de
l'Europe
Colombelles les deux églises par contre
où le voyage prit un aspect privé fut
une étape de détente consacrée en
quelque sorte aux relations de bon
voisinage
à Chaumont de nouveau le président de la
République devant une foule considérable
à traiter des problèmes de la
construction de l'Europe
qui ce voyage fut émaillé lui aussi
d'arrêt surprise Amani le général de
Gaulle teint à Salvé deux couples de
jeunes mariés il fut comme les
précédents celui des grands thèmes ce
que le chef de l'État a repris à trois
l'Europe l'Alliance atlantique la
détente le rôle de l'État et la
solidarité nationale
[Musique]
dans la banlieue de New York un banal
feux de broussailles a bien failli
tourner à la catastrophe favorisé par la
sécheresse inhabituelle de ces dernières
semaines et attisée par un banc violent
les flammes se sont propagées à une
vitesse foudroyante à travers une zone
résidentielle située entre Bayonne et
luxonne des milliers de pompiers venus
de New York et des environs aidé par de
nombreux volontaires ont luttait toute
une journée pour faire au feu une part
exceptionnellement belle 500 maisons et
1200 hectares calcinés par miracle il
n'y a que quatre morts la plupart des
demeures détruites étant des chalets de
weekends encore inoccupés
[Musique]
depuis quelques temps Vito petite
bourgade de Côte-d'Or s'interrogeait le
tout vit
o qui nous évident de perplexité il y
avait les pour et les contes il est vrai
que la question était de taille
laisserait-on détourner la route
nationale trop étroite ou pour la garder
au milieu de la commune
sacrifierait-on les halles des Halles
tout de même du 14e siècle
maintenant plus Vito organisa son
référendum et c'est ainsi que les
habitants d'un petit chef-lieu de canton
ce singularisèrent ce dimanche là en
prenant le chemin des urnes
la belle affaire direz-vous mais si Vito
allait être imité on ne sait jamais
exactement où commence une épidémie on
l'a bien vu avec le twist en tout cas il
n'y a plus de problèmes à vitaux
allègrement par 35 oui contre 65 non la
bourgade de Côte-d'Or a opté pour
l'élargissement de la rue
[Musique]
à l'abbaye de Westminster en présence
d'un parterre de têtes couronnée et de
2000 invités la princesse Margaret et la
reine Elizabeth sont venus assister au
mariage de leur cousines la princesse
Alexandra
conduite par son frère le duc de Kent
celle que les Anglais ont surnommé la
princesse souriante va être unie à
l'honorable vie second fils du comte
derli
[Musique]
c'est l'archevêque de kanterbury qui
célèbre le mariage selon le rite
anglican douzième dans l'ordre de
succession au trône la princesse
Alexandra a souvent remplacé la reine et
la princesse Margaret dans certaines
cérémonies officielles
derrière la traîne longue de 20 pieds on
a beaucoup remarqué la princesse Anne
devenue très jeune fille
[Musique]
la princesse Marina ma mère de la mariée
a été profondément ému du triomphe fait
par la foule aux jeunes époux qui vont
partir pour l'Écosse terre des ancêtres
de Monsieur Oggy
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est la fleur la plus répandue de tout
le règne végétal elle prolifèrent de
l'Amérique à l'Himalaya de Bali à Tahiti
et pourtant on lui consacre de laborieux
sculptures insert en Île-de-France par
exemple des études minutieuses et des
soins attentifs lui ont apporté la
perfection lui ont constitué son Gotha
[Musique]
telles sont en effet les orchidées d'une
graine il est toujours possible
d'obtenir mieux que la fleur qui la
produite mais au prix de quel patience
sélectionnez dans de petites
centrifugeuses les graines sont
ensemencées une à une dans une gélatine
très sucrée celle-ci remplace les
champignons auxquels les graines
sauvages empruntent habituellement leur
substance nutritive
techniquement fermé stériliser les
flacons doivent être étiquetés car on ne
les ouvrira plus avant un an c'est le
temps nécessaire pour que les plantules
aient atteint la taille suffisante qui
permettra de les repiquer dans une
mousse humide
et ce n'est pas fini de repiquerage en
repiquage 7 à 8 ans encore vont passer
avant qu'on obtienne la fleur attendue
la plus chère des fleurs
veut-on obtenir une nuance nouvelle
alors c'est un nouveau cycle qui
commence
un cycle qui va durer de 9 à 10 ans
depuis l'instant où la boule de pollen
est déposée sur le stigmate de la plante
jusqu'à celui qui verra éclore le
premier bouton sur le nouveau pied
d'orchidée
ainsi son nez dans les serres de la
tuilerie à Boissy-Saint-Léger pour être
exporté à travers le monde plus de 1000
variétés de ces fleurs étranges
le moins curieux n'est pas originaire
des tropiques les orchidées créent en
Île-de-France repartent par avion vers
leur pays d'origine pour y orner les
boutonnières ou les appartements c'est
dire le prestige des orchidées de
culture comme le fascinant l'inquiétant
sabot de Vénus
avec les beaux jours on recommence la
valse des records sur les stades
d'athlétisme une valse qui prend la
tournure d'un feu d'artifice pour les
sauteurs à la perche américaine à
Philadelphie Steinberg et le premier
athlète à franchir les 100 mètres mais
stanberg ignorait que son triomphe
serait de courte durée trois jours plus
tard son compatriote John Pennel
franchissait 5m04 l'émulation aidant ils
finiront par aller dans la Lune vous
verrez
de son côté l'athlète de Formose young
Shui a crevé le plafond du décathlon le
décathlon c'est l'épreuve des hommes qui
savent tout faire courir sauter ou bien
lancer un poids un javelot ou un disque
sait faire tout cela et comme il le fait
bien il a pulvérisé le record du monde
il a même en passant essayé de faire
mieux que Steinberg à la perche mais là
il a échoué il faut bien laisser
quelques records aux autres tout de même
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les redoutable kamikaze japonais c'était
promis de torpiller comme de vulgaires
croiseurs de bataille les catcheurs
mondiaux les plus réputés ici Gilbert
Leduc et Jacky corne
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dès les premiers échanges la fourberie
des catcheurs suicides s'étale au grand
jour
et seul un sursaut désespéré sauvera le
français d'une infamante d'État
asiat dont l'un ici va faire passer à
son adversaire un désagréable quart
d'heure qui aurait pu être le dernier si
le renfort attendu avec quelques peu
tardé
dans un climat passionné le représentant
de l'Occident va faire mieux que saint
Michel en terrassant successivement les
deux dragons et notre justicier envoie
le kamikazé faire un magistral piqué
dans l'océan des fauteuils d'orchestre
Blanchette japonaise pour le Nippon
sérieusement malmené et le français
écarte définitivement le péril en
descendant en flamme l'orgueilleux
kamikaze
Jacky corne et Gilbert Leduc vainqueur
une fois c'est le bon départ
c'est la grande mutation qui a ramené
les bourgeons sur les branches les
citadins à la campagne Candida son
jardin et Mimi Pinson à sa fenêtre c'est
l'explosion de toute la nature qui a
fait refleurir jusqu'au plat de vente de
Jean Barthès le melon et le canotier
tiennent le haut du châssis avec la
cloche fleurie comme un pommier du Japon
autant de petits jardins gracieusement
suspendus dans le mois babylonien des
décors
[Musique]
l'un s'appelle rue du soleil tout un
programme l'autre rue de Bourgogne comme
l'hôtel dans lequel monsieur de
bergeracuttin duel rapprochement gratuit
car le fond attire moins l'épée que les
fléchettes
à gauche Victor je suis tweet voyez mon
grain éternel féminin changeante et
illusoire
[Musique]
je suis broderie anglaise je suis
Capline voyez mes bords éternel féminin
fantasque et versatile je suis toc
il tourne les têtes et retourne les
chapeaux c'est le printemps
[Musique]
i comme chaque année les fort des Halles
leur reine et ses demoiselles d'honneur
sont venus offrir aux présidents de la
République et à Madame De Gaulle le
muguet du premier mai un 1er mai dont le
général de Gaulle a dit qu'il était fait
du printemps fête du Travail et fête de
la paix
à Moscou le premier mai a pris la forme
habituelle du défilé de masse sur la
Place Rouge il a constitué pour l'autre
de Monsieur crotchav Fidel Castro le
point culminant d'un séjour uniformément
triomphale
la présence du président cubain dans la
tribune officielle a eu entre autres
conséquences celle de provoquer
l'absence des représentants de
l'ambassade des États-Unis
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
un 1er mai moscovite en tout point égal
à sa tradition
nelle aussi le premier mai à Pékin à
ceci près qu'il n'y avait pas de
personnalité de la taille de Fidel
Castro à offrir à la foule chinoise
[Applaudissements]
monsieur schwen Lay et les dirigeants de
la Chine populaire ont participé à
l'immense kermesse qui est ici la fête
du travail au milieu de 4 millions
d'habitants
[Musique]
amené par l'ancien yacht du roi Farouk
qui porte aujourd'hui le nom de liberté
le président Gamal Abdel Nasser a rendu
sa première visite à Alger
un an après la fin de la guerre
d'Algérie la population de la capitale a
réservé avec Monsieur Benbella un
accueil enthousiaste à celui que l'on
appelait le grand frère
[Applaudissements]
accueille si enthousiaste que les deux
hommes durent abandonné leur automobile
pour une voiture de pompier afin
d'achever la traversée de la ville le
drapeau de la République arabes unique
comptera-t-il un jour 5 étoiles la
cinquième représentant l'Algérie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
différence inter-africaine Davis à Beva
problème des regroupements en cours au
prochain tels allaient être les
principaux thèmes des entretiens
politiques des deux hommes d'État
[Applaudissements]
pabble de transporter dans ses soutes 8
à 15 tonnes de fret d'une remarquable
maniabilité tel est le nouvel appareil
de transport militaire que Monsieur
Messmer ministre des Armées et Monsieur
fanassel son collègue de l'Allemagne
fédéral en vue décoller en 200 mètres
sur le terrain d'Istres fruits de la
coopération franco-allemande le Transall
C160 qui effectuait son premier vol
public cette affaire le luxe de
plusieurs passages suivi de virages en S
avec un moteur arrêté
[Musique]
ce wagon de chemin de fer volant peut
franchir 4500 km à une vitesse de
croisière de 500 km heure
[Musique]
qui n'a pas vu la route à l'aube toute
fraîche toute vivante ne sait pas ce que
c'est que l'espérance cette pensée de
Bernanos a sans doute soutenue la
plupart des 9000 étudiants en rupture de
laboratoire et d'amphithéâtre qui ont
participé aux traditionnels pèlerinages
de charme
cette traversée de la Beauce a été une
épreuve volontaire pour ses modernes
croisés partie de Rambouillet et
dépernons ils avaient retrouvé à travers
les blés naissants les traces et la foi
des pèlerins de jadis
mais 50 km de marche pour des jeunes
gens et des jeunes filles non entraînés
nécessité à l'étape quelques réconforts
tandis que les confessions redonnaient
leur vrai sens à cette marge vers la
lumière
[Musique]
Paris
et c'est avec une joie sans mélange que
les jeunes pèlerins ont vu enfin surgir
la flèche irréprochable
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dans la lumière d'un pari de printemps
s'est déroulée la cérémonie anniversaire
de la victoire de 1945 le général de
Gaulle a remonté les Champs-Élysées pour
aller s'incliner sur la tombe du soldat
inconnu minute de recueillement et de
souvenirs
quelques heures plus tôt à Orléans le
Premier ministre célébrait le 534e
anniversaire d'une autre libération en
1429 Jeanne d'Arc hier simple bergère
signait par la libération d'Orléans le
premier acte majeur de sa grandiose
histoire Orléans n'a jamais cessé depuis
de commémorer cette journée quel
français par ailleurs ne garde dans son
cœur une place pour cet enfant de Don
Rémy dont la maison est restée intacte
foyer elle médite assez sombre
elle a connu le jour de cette fenêtre
étroite et cette armoire a renfermé ses
habits
mais le pays entier parle de Jeanne
de la prairie où elle jouait avec ses
compagnes jusqu'à la fontaine des
fiévreux combragaient peut-être à cette
époque le fameux arbre des fées près
duquel elle écouta ses voix
[Musique]
elle dit adieu à tout cela un jour à
l'appel de sa mission
à vos couleurs se trouvent toujours la
chapelle où Jeanne attendit toute une
nuit la permission du cire de
Baudricourt d'aller rachido
et c'est par cette porte de France
quelle partie pour accomplir ce destin
merveilleux et tragique qui devait la
conduire à Orléans et à Reims pour finir
sur le bûcher de Rouen
[Musique]
le Festival de Cannes qui transforme
chaque année pour trois semaines la vie
des canards a pris le départ avec la
Bégum une habituée quelques vedettes
japonaises des passantes et Robert
Hossein ce sont 2000 invités venues de
30 pays stars starlette réalisateur
producteurs qui vont voir défiler
quelques 200 films c'est à dire quelques
400 km de pellicule
c'est Hitchcock qui a ouvert le feu avec
sa vedette tipi et de Rennes et son film
les oiseaux
[Musique]
et voici comment les oiseaux se vendent
à Saclay Monsieur Francis Perrin a
visité une exposition dans les vedettes
étaient les robots de l'âge atomique
ses bras de métal au pince menaçante que
l'homme s'est inventé pour travailler à
l'abri des radiations pour les
techniciens il s'agit très prosaïquement
de télé manipulateurs
[Musique]
les plus lourds Ali la puissance à la
précision ce qui n'exclut pas la plus
grande délicatesse et tel d'entre eux
qui peut soulever 300 kg peut aussi bien
saisir un œuf
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les ingénieurs atomistes disposent même
aujourd'hui d'une véritable main de
rechange ce qui tendrait à prouver que
la main est le plus parfait des robots
[Musique]
une nouvelle crise secoue le sud des
États-Unis à Birmingham en Alabama des
manifestations de la population noire en
faveur de l'égalité raciale ont dégénéré
en hurt violent au cours desquels la
police a procédé à plus de 2000
arrestations il y a eu également des
blessés par disait
[Musique]
la police a fait appel au lance des
pompiers dont le gel est assez puissant
pour briser la main comme au chien
policier
triste renouveau d'un problème
dramatique dont le président Kennedy a
au dernier nouvelle décidé de se mêler
malgré l'opposition du gouverneur de
l'Alabama
[Musique]
les visages charmants qui sont ceux de
l'enfance ne sauraient plus aujourd'hui
faire illusion depuis que ce sont
développés les techniques de la
psychanalyse fondée sur les théories de
Sigmund Freud les psychologues sont
habilles à découvrir au détour d'un
dessin le contenu complexe du lame
infantile révolte contre l'école et
l'autorité paternelle par exemple
révélée par l'inversion volontaire des
lettres
[Musique]
l'origine de bien des comportements
étranges apparaît ainsi en clair
inquiétude d'aller de l'avant
sensation d'être abandonné
crainte inconsciente d'une hypothétique
menace
[Musique]
quant au sentiment d'agressivité il
s'exprime à travers tout un monde peuplé
d'armes à feu
que les parents se consolent donc ils ne
sont plus sans ressource même en face
des cas les plus désespérés même en face
de ce garnement en apparence le plus
affreux qu'on puisse imaginer
[Musique]
celui-ci qui ne respectait rien que ses
camarades craignent Et que ces maîtres
finissent eux aussi par redouter et pour
cause
[Musique]
véritable démon terreur de la classe
abonné au panoplie de cowboy c'est
évidemment le jeune fauve type que des
parents trop faibles ont renoncé à
dompter
[Musique]
celui dont le carnet de notes
particulièrement éloquant clair est une
atmosphère de deuil illimité et s'il
n'avait depuis longtemps sur un verset
la situation en y glissant par exemple
en prévision de la fête des mères un
billet de la Loterie Nationale
tout innocence bien sûr le brave petit
que les amis des pigeons pour qu'il ait
Bizet et autres palombes sont un des
charmes de Paris en même temps que le
symbole et les de l'amour fidèle sera
sûr la dépigénisation n'est pas
l'extermination
seulement devant l'accumulation de
méfaits caractériser et l'affichage d'un
sans-gêne qui confine parfois au crime
de l’aise majesté il fallait bien agir
la bonne tenue des monuments publics
leur réclamait l'intérêt de la propriété
privée l'exigeait disons qu'à l'heure où
Paris avait entrepris sa grande
opération de ravalement pour retrouver
sa blancheur originelle le souci des
édiles rejoignait celui de certains
particuliers en lutte ouverte avec les
pigeons restaient la manière pas
question évidemment de barder les
bâtiments d'épouvantail étaitroclite
[Musique]
la destruction systématique des œufs
les pigeons font 9 couvés par an
quand à l'intervention violente les
pauvres ne méritent pas cela
alors des équipes ont été chargés de
parcourir Paris à l'heure des repas pour
les capturer au filet en douceur
[Musique]
que les amis des bêtes soient totalement
tranquillisées ces captures ne préluent
nullement à de sanguinaires hécatonges
elles n'ont pour but que d'éloigner le
pari 40 000 pigeons sur les 80000 qui
vivent aujourd'hui ce qui est vraiment
trop
on ne pouvait naître plus de forme au
règlement de ce problème même en cage
ils sont traités avec les plus grands
égards
puis ils sont conduits par compagnie
entière chaque fin de semaine vers un
coin de campagne
[Musique]
là c'est pigeons qui selon les
spécialistes ont toujours joui d'un
tempérament casanier se fixeront et
pourront en somme refaire leur vie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dans son strict uniforme de 1940 le
Général de Gaulle a reçu de la foule
athénienne un accueil inoubliable entre
les deux haies populaires qui lui criait
leur amitié le président de la
République aux côtés du roi Paul a fait
son entrée dans sa terre et peut-être
cet accueillanthusiaste s'explique-t-il
par la fraternité mais du passé de deux
pays qui furent les berceaux de la
civilisation et de la liberté
cette visite à la famille royale de
Grèce avait dès les premiers mots
déterminés son sens face à un avenir
chargé d'inquiétude et d'espoir la
France et la Grèce veulent conjuguer
leurs efforts
ce sens de la rencontre le général de
Gaulle devait le confirmer dans cette
sorte de pèlerinage aux sources de
l'humanisme occidentale devant
l'Acropole devant les vestiges dorés qui
retracent la marche en avant de l'esprit
humain puisqu'il s'est appelé d'abord
praxitel et selon Phidias et Platon
Homère et Aristote
[Musique]
l'accueil des villages de la tique fut
égal à celui de la capitale
au milieu de ces groupes de paysans et
d'ouvriers le général de Gaulle refit le
geste qu'il fait en France se mêlant
simplement à la foule grecque comme il
se mêle au Full français
[Musique]
mais la grande leçon de ce voyage devait
se dégager à Salonique d'abord au
cimetière militaire où dorment de leur
dernier sommeil plus de 8000 soldats
français tombés sur le sol grec pendant
la Première Guerre mondiale signé
mouvant d'une fraternité d'armes qui
s'ajoute à la fraternité de culture et
d'esprit
ensuite au cours du grand défilé qui
unissait les marins français aux unités
hellénique de toutes armes
c'était là l'illustration vivante de la
déclaration qui avait faite devant le
parlement grec le général de Gaulle
votre défense c'est l'anneau si nous
appartenons vous et nous à l'Alliance
atlantique c'est avec la conviction
qu'il n'y a pas pour les peuples libres
d'autres garanties de la paix
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
sans doute faudra-t-il encore du temps
pour que dans le sud des États-Unis les
problèmes ratiaux perdent leur acuité
actuelle la population noire n'a pas
renoncé à ces manifestations contre la
ségrégation et toutes ne se sont pas
achevés avec la même simplicité dans les
quarts de la police
dans le Tennessee comme un burmingham en
Alabama les manifestants noirs qui
s'étaient réunis devant les restaurants
ségrégationnistes n'ont pas cédé la
place sans résistance
[Applaudissements]
la présence des forces fédérales
envoyées par le président Kennedy
marquera-t-elle définitivement le
commencement de la sagesse elle
préviendra on l'espère le retour de ses
affrontements tragiques entre les deux
populations
[Applaudissements]
à Cannes monsieur fourré Cormeray
directeur de la cinématographie
française a bien voulu honorer d'une
particulière attention les travaux du
18e congrès de la Fédération Nationale
des Cinémas Français avant leur entrée
en séance les délégués se sont-ils fait
prédire par cette jeune vedette l'avenir
du cinéma et c'est délicats rapports
avec la télévision
[Musique]
tandis que la fusée Atlas brillait sous
les projecteurs de Cap Canaveral Gordon
Cooper s'apprêtait à vivre la grande
aventure de l'espace il refaisait un à
un les gestes qui avaient fait les cinq
américains venus avant lui à ce
rendez-vous du petit matin chez Bard
Greyson Glenn Carpenter et Skira
[Musique]
mais cette fois dans la capsule Mercury
tapissé de cadran le coupeur devait
passer près de 34 heures le temps de
boucler 22 fois le tour de la terre
l'aube Solvay quand sa cheval compte à
rebours
[Musique]
toute l'Amérique puis suivre les images
transmises en direct de Cap Canaveral de
la mission orbite du 10e homme de
l'espace
si les 22 révolutions de Gordon Cooper
furent sans histoire il n'en a pas même
du retour dans l'atmosphère le contrôle
automatique était en panne d'un
porte-avions croisant au sud du Japon
Glenn suivait seconde par seconde les
opérations sur ces indications coupeur
alluma lui-même les rétrofusés de
freinage les largas puis opéra sa
stabilisation
opération capitale puisque faute
d'aborder la couche atmosphérique dans
l'angle voulu la cabine risquait de
fondre
à 7000 mètres le premier parachute de
freinage s'ouvrait normalement
[Musique]
à 3500 mètres le grand parachute se
déployait à son tour mieux la cabine de
Cooper touchait la mer à moins de 4 km
du porte-avion chargé avec 27 autres
navires et 172 avions de la récupérer
grand succès pour la mairie et Gordon
Cooper avait bien mérité le surnom de
cosmonaute tranquille que le monde lui a
donné
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Saint Pierre et Miquelon donnons
inséparables qui chantent dans la
mémoire depuis l'école c'est aussi à
4000 km de Paris 240 km² de France c'est
même un coin de Bretagne et de Pays
Basque réunis sous les brouillards de
ternes le roi de Grande-Bretagne dit le
traité de Paris la restituer en 1763 à
Sa Majesté très chrétienne pour servir
d'abris aux pêcheurs français
juste deux siècles plus tard toujours
gardiques par ces quatre canons de
bronze Saint-Pierre la capitale qui
groupe 4500 et 5000 habitants de
l'archipel n'est pas autre chose
aujourd'hui qu'importe de pêche délaissé
par les équipages français
un unique navire le micro assure la
liaison avec le Canada
un modeste aérodrome ignorait des
Boeings et autres caravelles mais son
orgueil dans ses appareils de 3 et 4
places
[Musique]
la station radio est bien défendue avis
aux mauvais coupscheurs qui en aurait
contre Dalida ou Johnny Hallyday
les chemins ici ne viennent de nulle
part et ne vont qu'à Saint-Pierre un
panneau n'en n'annonce pas moins
l'entrée de la cité
construite en bois à la mode canadienne
Saint-Pierre il faut le dire à la
passion des panneaux elle en possède
trois qui interdisent le stationnement
au même endroit ou à peu près et une
belle collection de sens interdit
on se croirait à Paris à cette
différence près que le contractuel local
c'est toujours obstinément refusé à
dresser la moindre contravention aux
rares automobilistes
[Musique]
autour de son clocher vite ainsi sans
histoires une population de basques de
Bretons et de Normands descendant des
premiers pêcheurs établis dans
l'archipel comme Alain derneau les
enfants jouent à la marelle et comme à
Saint-Jean-de-Luz d'autres se retrouvent
devant le fronton de plates
[Musique]
un coin de France comme tant d'autres
avec ses 11 gendarmes chargés d'assurer
le respect de la loi encore qu'on n'est
pas ici le souvenir d'un seul petit
crime un détail pourtant les îles ont
leur monnaie c'est que Saint Pierre et
Miquelon ne forment pas un département
mais un territoire d'outre-mer avec à
leur tête un administrateur à ses côtés
un député un sénateur 14 conseillers
généraux un maire fidèle au béret basque
et un président du syndicat d'initiative
avec une température moyenne de 5 degrés
la vie n'est pas particulièrement douce
pour les habitants l'activité tourne
autour de l'élevage des animaux à
fourrure renard bleu et renard argenté
qui peut encore prendre une certaine
extension
[Musique]
comme l'élevage du vison qui s'est
nettement affirmé depuis une quinzaine
d'années mais c'est surtout la mère qui
demeure la vraie dispensatrice des
ressources la mer si essentielle et si
présente que les tombes du cimetière ont
des hublots pour permettre aux morts de
l'entendre encore
la mer qui reste le seul avenir de
Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon le port moderne
dont la construction est envisagée
ramènera les équipages français sur ces
grèves aujourd'hui fréquentées par des
bandes de chevaux que leurs oisiveté a
rendu à l'état sauvage
[Musique]
à Paris le général de Gaulle a présidé
la célébration solennelle du centenaire
de la Croix-Rouge dont le nom est
inséparable de celui d'Henri du Nord ce
jeune voix de 31 ans qui avec 4 de ses
concitoyens avaient entrepris voici 100
ans de faire partager au monde l'horreur
que lui avait inspiré sur le champ de
bataille de Solférino les souffrances de
40 000 blessés
[Musique]
dès 1863 leur initiative s'était
traduite par la création du Comité
international de secours aux militaires
blessés l'année suivante 16 pays signé
dans la salle de l'Alabama la Convention
de Genève et le premier ordre de mission
porte la date de mars 1864
la guerre de 70 le siège de Paris vire
la Croix-Rouge multipliait
de s'étendre dans le monde entier
alors où la Croix-Rouge française vient
de fleurir le tombeau du soldat inconnu
160 millions de volontaires poursuivent
aujourd'hui la tâche d'Henri Dunant
[Musique]
à Paris au ministère des Affaires
étrangères les conversations
franco-guinéennes se sont achevés par
une signature en présence de Monsieur
tridoulet ministre de la Coopération
messieurs se foulaye Diallo Chef de la
délégation guinéenne et Louis Jox
ministre d'État ont signé une série
d’accords qui après 5 ans de séparation
ouvre une aire de coopération entre les
deux pays
[Musique]
aucun des honneurs classiques aux
États-Unis n'aura manqué à Cooper à son
retour du cosmos il a parcouru Broadway
sous la pluie de confettis et de
serpentins que l'Amérique réserve à ses
héros comme le signe même du triomphe
c'est d'ailleurs paraît-il la pluie de
papier la plus épaisse qu'on ait vu de
mémoire de New York
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais il est sûr que rien ne aura valu
pour l'astronaute au 22 tours la joie de
retrouver sa femme et ses filles à son
arrivée à Hawaii au lendemain de son
retour
un sourire vaut quelquefois toutes les
gloires
Arnaud salacou président du jury du 16e
Festival de Cannes en présence du
ministre de la Formation Monsieur Alain
Peyrefitte à félicité lukinovisconti qui
recevait des mains de Jeanne Moreau la
palme d'or pour son film Le Guépard et
le prix spécial du jury a été décerné au
film japonais Araki
par ailleurs le prix d'interprétation
féminine est allé à Marina Vlady
récompense applaudit mais aussi discuté
mais le 16e Festival de Cannes n'en aura
pas moins connu son succès habituel
[Musique]
depuis 62 ans qu'il existe le concours
Lépine ne compte plus ses succès mais on
n'avait pas encore trouvé le
tire-bouchon automatique justement le
voici
[Musique]
cette invention nettement marquée par
l’époque n'a réduit en rien la floraison
des pédaliers améliorés c'est pourquoi
nous sommes allés voir le doyen des
petits inventeurs pierre de Vitry qui a
plusieurs gros succès à son actif
notamment le pipi lumineux
en 1892 à Charenton j'ai des globules
Auvergnate et Frank Antoine j'ai
commencé les inventions alors je de 12
ans donc comme vous voyez je suis
l'inventeur des lumineux sur tous les
toits des taxis
plus de 60 inventions sont l’œuvre de ce
chercheur infatigable dont le registre
s'étend du chausse pied à brosse
incorporée aux multiples gadgets
motocyclistes dont les usagers de la
route tiraient bon profit et dont les
brevets sont libres pour le monde entier
[Musique]
en 1950 j'avais fait un bâton lui-même
était dur et comme j'avais de temps en
temps à Cannes les agents là-bas m'ont
demandé que je leur passe inventant mais
souffle voyez-vous il est souple vous
avez un bout
une gentille pour éclairer les papiers
vous avez ici le stop vous avez le porte
au crayon et vous avez ainsi fait
sous l'Occupation m'avait volé un vélo
réveillez-vous ce que j'avais fabriqué
c'est un bouchon qui est placé sous la
fiche de sel et qui traverse alors le
plus beau c'est d'avoir le type sautant
sur le vélo en voltige il va pas bien
loin il descend aussi sec
dans ce domaine de la défense et de
l'antivol on le voit pierre de Vitry
ancien chauffeur de taxi et réellement
passé mais
face à
la Marne il fallait aussi trouver
quelque chose
[Musique]
trois départements français en état de
mort lente vouée au garrigues aux
oliviers rabougri à une production
viticole sans qualité telle était la
région du baron et du Languedoc voici 5
ans lorsque des bulldozers commencèrent
à creuser un profond sillon de 25 mètres
de large ainsi pour les corps un projet
d'irrigation né disons le tout bas en
1847 il s'agissait de créer un fleuve
artificiel de 280 km de Tarascon à
Narbonne de façon à irriguer 200000
hectares de terre
[Musique]
la technique moderne a fait avancer
rapidement ce nouveau travail d'Hercule
au sud de Beaucaire le Rhône donne
aujourd'hui naissance à une voix d'eau
dont le débit 75 mètres cubes par
seconde et celui de la scène et qui
constitue la Morse d’une des entreprises
hydrauliques les plus importantes du
monde et en même temps des plus
audacieuses au bout de 12 km ne
fallait-il pas brusquement élevé de 30
mètres cette masse d'eau
on édifia dans ce but à Peach grue la
plus puissante station de pompage
existantes et un seul homme aujourd'hui
préside à ce défi permanent lancé à la
nature faire couler en quelque sorte un
fleuve à l'envers
grâce à ce tour de force l'eau du Rhône
peut toujours aller redonner la vie à
une région qui devenait peu à peu un
désert
[Musique]
dès cette année un gigantesque jardin
potager et fruitier de 40 000 hectares
s'étend sur les rives du nouveau canal
[Musique]
là où l'aridité avait fait abandonner
les terres là où elle avait chassé les
hommes et fait mourir les villages et
née l'embryon d'une Californie française
qui dans 10 ans couvrira 200 000
hectares
[Musique]
de nombreux châteaux d'eau recréés
aujourd'hui ce qui manquait à ce pays
brûlé par un ensoleillement quasi
permanent la pluie vivifiante
conséquence de cette renaissance
agricole un premier Marché Gare est né à
Nîmes saint Césaire d'autres suivront
ainsi toute une région jusqu'à
maintenant déshérité est en train de
devenir une des plus riches de France
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]